are you going to get a cop 27  yes as it happens but um that's  that's not relevant to Ukraine and final  question I mean do you still Harbor  Hotel I was invited by his invited by  the by the Egyptians  and you presumably think the Prime  Minister should go I think the the  premise is doing uh as as he's pointed  out he's got a massive amount to do  we've got to sort out uh a huge  agenda that's what he's getting on with  um I haven't had a particular I was at  the Glasgow cop although it's become  unfashionable to talk about it was a  fantastic Global success we did a huge  amount of good for the planet I want to  talk a little bit about uh how uh I see  things and how we see things in the UK